there's a reason Joe Biden ran the way
he did there's a reason he's running for
democracy now because that's really
what's at stake you worried that you
can't pay your bill we have not shown a
clip have we shown a clip in the New
Year from The View I think this is our
first view clip of the year here's once
sane actress whoopy Goldberg telling you
how horrible you are and Republicans are
mean and a bunch more I'm sorry what's
interesting for me is
that
people's faith in the country is waning
that's the that's the thing that's
pissing me off because in fact there's a
reason Joe Biden ran the way he did
there's a reason he's running for
democracy now because that's really
what's at stake you worried that you
can't pay your bill wait till he the
other guy becomes president and you
won't have to worry about it cuz you'll
be in some Camp somewhere cuz that's his
promise his promise to us is he's going
to force people
to do his bidding that's what he said
I'm with this I'm going to be good on
day one and I'm going to turn into this
other person so here's the deal this is
all up to you this is all up to you we
can sit up here till we're Green in the
face but this really comes down to the
people what is the country you want do
you want the country that you kind of
thought you had where we all get to say
what we think and we don't have to be
afraid of being American and believe
that yeah there will be people who come
in and some will get in quick and some
will take a different route but they're
coming here for a reason cuz they're
living in a place that's not good for
their families if you're okay with that
you understand that then fight for us to
find a better way to make immigration
work fight for that don't fight for
keeping everybody out because then we
all have to leave whoop is worth a cool
60 mil I wonder how much of that maybe
we can send an email to her represent
resentatives how much she'll be putting
towards building housing for these
people maybe she could let a couple
people in her house that would be real
nice of of whoopy to do right there um
of course everything she's saying again
it's the reverse of the truth right
she's saying that the Republicans will
crash the economy the economy was
actually doing unbelievably well under
Trump before covid right Co obviously
changed the game on that and we that's a
kind of separate issue altoe again this
thing about we're nice so we want people
to come in to the country they're nice
so they don't so what they're doing in
essence is they're not only blaming
Republicans for the Border even though
Republicans are not in charge of the
border of the country right now but
they're also they're also blaming you
for being concerned with what you see
right in front of you right so it's like
Republicans are really mean and look
what they do and that guy from Texas the
white guy sends it to the black mayor in
Chicago and and then also if you notice
that oh it is a little odd that
thousands of 25-year-old men who look
perfectly healthy and wellfed are
streaming into our country you're
somehow a racist and it's also you the
bad
guy